hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about future of Science
and Technology I am not in my natural
habitat today so if strange things go
wrong apologies for that in
advance all right let's see we have a
bunch of questions saved up here one
from
James what scientific breakthroughs
would you like to see in
2024 I think the most exciting
breakthroughs will always be the ones
that we don't expect are coming there
are ones where they are sort of long
anticipated and then they finally arrive
and there are ones where kind of nobody
saw that coming in terms of things that
I'm personally involved in there are
it's kind of I we're at a just an
amazing point because a lot of things
that I've worked on for a really long
time uh have sort of come to fruition
recently from our physics project to all
the implications of the physics project
the ruad all these kinds of things there
are several pieces of that that I'd love
to see make big progress in
2024 uh one of them is what we're
calling infr geometry which is kind of
generalizing the ideas of how one
constructs the mathematics of space
calculus things like this starting not
from the traditional idea of continuous
space that has existed since uid and so
on but rather from the idea of these
graphs networks hypergraphs making up
the underlying stuff of space and
there's kind of a different development
of what ends up with things like
calculus and differential geometry and
so on that starts not from the idea of a
manifold and idian space and so on but
rather from this underlying structure of
networks that's one area where I hope to
see big progress made um in in the
course of this year and it's kind of is
kind of interesting because it's kind of
a rebuilding of all of the Notions of
calculus you know people study for
example calculus one variable two
variables Etc one of the things we need
to be able to construct is calculus of
two and three4 variables it's just
something for which the mathematics
really doesn't exist but it's a
development that uh we're progressing
with and I hope this year we'll make
lots of progress on
another piece of that story is uh things
about our physics project
and figuring out more about sort of how
to connect the
underlying uh machine code of the
universe as our physics project suggests
it with the actual experimental
observations that can be made and it's a
complicated Road understanding sort of
what implications are there for Black
Hole mergers what implications are there
for the cosmic microwave background and
so on from our physics project uh what
does a dimension fluctuation look like
in in cosmology as physics what um uh
what might we be able to say from our
new view of quantum mechanics about the
things that are done in Quantum
Computing one of the things that I think
is is uh quantum computers are
conceptually interesting uh a good
practical way to push the development of
computational Hardware that isn't based
on semiconductors and electronics but I
think there are sort of problems with
the sort of the interpretation of of
with with actually the sort of the
quantum flag for the things that people
talk about as Quantum Computing my own
guess is that the things that go wrong
the decoherence the errors all this kind
of thing that actually there's a lot of
interesting information there that may
very well be very much informed by the
kinds of things that we're doing in our
physics project because our physics
project goes underneath the traditional
View and quantum mechanics which says
okay and now you go from all these
probabilities and and Quantum amplitudes
and so on and you make a measurement and
that's just one kind of discrete act in
our in our physics project one's able to
sort of take apart that measurement
process and understand it in more detail
and I think that what we see as we
compare that with experiment May well
actually reveal features of what's going
on that uh sort of allow one to see into
kind of the discrete multi-way structure
of space and time and quantum mechanics
and so on which would be which would be
exciting but seeing how that works is is
a challenge and um uh of course it will
be really neat I don't expect that this
year um to actually make the connection
between our models of physics and
discreetness of SpaceTime and so on and
actual experimental observations I don't
expect that to happen in a time as short
as a year I think in a year we may know
sort of what there is to look for and
then the actual mounting of the
experiment is it is a non-trivial matter
I mean if we're lucky there will be
things that have already been observed
long ago go but we can now just say oh
we understand that
now so other things that um I'm kind of
hoping will emerge in the next year
perhaps some progress on Observer Theory
which I've just recently been talking
about and understanding kind of how um
sort of what observers like us are like
and how much of what we perceive in the
universe is a consequence of our
features as observers and being able to
home in on what is the sort of overall
description of what observers do when it
comes to observers with human senses or
observers with measuring devices and so
on that's another place where I think
progress can be made and where the
Leverage is very high because I think uh
what seems to be the cases that just two
attributes of us as observers that we're
computationally bounded that we believe
we're persistent in time just those two
attributes are sufficient to give us big
the big theories of 20th century physics
so as we add more attributes that are
sort of characteristics that we as
observers have I suspect we will learn
more about sort of the inevitability of
laws of physics as as we are going to
perceive
them so uh other kinds of things well
gosh there so much um
from our physics project in particular
uh I think two areas where I'm hoping
for Progress one is biology the other is
economics um in biology sort of the big
issue as far as I'm concerned is is what
what kind of overall theory for biology
can one get that is kind of is a is a a
kind of a large scale computational
description of what's going on you know
what when you look at molecular biology
what is the kind of what kind of thing
is biological tissue it's not like a
liquid quite it's something where
there's this kind of or uh bulk
orchestration of of pro of of molecular
processes and I'm hoping we'll make some
prog progress on that um in the next in
the next year uh in very different area
of
Economics I've long been very curious
what sort of a foundational theory of
Economics might look like and this kind
of whole structure of lots of events in
space time interacting with each other
that seems like something that um will
be uh uh will will be um
um the the that that that's that's kind
of like these events in SpaceTime are
kind of like all the transactions
happening in an economic system being
knitted together and then the question
is what's sort of the aggregate behavior
in the case of SpaceTime we think it's
things like gravity and the Einstein
equations and so on what are the
analogous things in economic systems so
those are a couple of things there there
are other directions uh there are a lot
of old chestnuts which I think have the
chance to be I don't quite know what you
do with an old Chestnut maybe you uh you
boil it and eat it or or something I'm
not sure but but um resolved in some way
I mean another sort of collection of old
chestnuts are things like computational
complexity Theory and the P versus NP
problem and so on in our kind of view of
the ruad and this kind of structure of
all possible
computations that the P versus MP
problem becomes essentially a something
which is a geometri problem it's
something which can really talk about
the structure of Ral space and I don't
know I'm not sure that's quite on the
agenda for the next year but it will be
really nice I think there is the
potential to make progress on that kind
of Old Chestnut well at least what is it
from about 1970s so it's a a 50e
chestnut so to speak um that uh of uh
that I think we might be able to make
progress on with with the techniques
that we now have um I think there are
there are other things that are a little
bit more longer time scale than than the
year
um that uh uh having to do with kind of
understandings of distributed computing
progress made there those kinds of
things another big area um in sort of
things that could happen in the span of
a year llms arrived pretty much in their
working form as chat gbt over the last
basically year or so I think the big
science question there is how do they
work and why do they work I've tried to
analyze this a bit but there's vastly
more that can be done to what extent can
we find for example semantic Laws of
Motion given that you said these things
what is the inevitable sort of
progression of things that make sense
that you have to say next the llm is
finding the things that you say next
that agree with kind of the training
that it's had from from all those things
it found from the web and so on um but
the question is what what kind of Theory
are there laws of motion and analogous
to the laws of motion and mechanics that
say in meaning space if you're going in
this direction you're going to have to
inexorably go like this is there kind of
a semantic grammar of language that
gives you a kind of construction kit for
language that's analogous to the kind of
noun follows verb follows noun um the uh
that um uh we have in kind of the
syntactic grammar of of of language so
sort of llm science is an area where I
think lots of interesting progress could
be made kind of really figuring out in
the end is there a narrative description
of what's going on inside an llm Beyond
just saying oh there are all these
complicated layers and Transformers and
this and that and the other and it was
all mushed together with training and uh
that's how it works is there something
more narrative that can be said is there
something more science like more you
know science is really the translation
of what exists out in the world the
things that we humans can think with the
that that we humans can kind of
understand and have a narrative about is
that possible in llms I think the answer
will be to some extent yes um and I
think that uh will be an important thing
and I think that's a fairly short time
scale thing I think when we understand
that it will probably tell us a lot
about Neuroscience because in
Neuroscience sort of one of the biggest
challenges has been this we just don't
know this intermediate level between
sort of a bunch of neuron firings and
the level of sort of psychologically
describable thoughts and I think that
sort of intermediate level is the kind
of thing that we can now get to explore
with llms llms are I think an emerging
really quite good model of Neuroscience
not at the level of individual neurons
and what they do and the details of the
electrochemistry of neurons but at some
at some bigger level in the same sense
that you know a touring machine is a
model of computation it doesn't have the
details of of electronics and and you
know Field Effect transistors and things
like this because that turns out not to
matter in understanding kind of broader
questions about computation so I think
the same will be true about sort of
Neuroscience versus
llms other areas of of science where
progress might get made I mean I I
mentioned things in physics and you know
there are some old chestnuts there like
the 100e old Chestnut of what is dark
matter why the rotation curves of
galaxies seem like there's m there's
something in galaxies that isn't the
Luminous matter and stars and so on what
is it how does that work I have some
guesses from my physics project about
how what I've been sort of tentatively
calling space-time heat might be kind of
the the the thing that leads to the
effects on SpaceTime that we right now
would describe as dark matter in in that
interpretation it's not really matter in
the same sense that uh that other things
are sort of made of atoms that you can
pick up and so on
other areas well I mean there's a lot of
areas in biom medicine where slow
progress will get made I mean I think
the um uh it's interesting that for
example an area like aging I sort of was
interested even from when I was vastly
younger 40 years ago whatever of you
know what is aging how does it work you
know will we be able to solve it so to
speak and uh nobody was working on it
back in those days gradually aging has
become a more and more popular kind of
topic to study and there's sort of slow
progress of particular in particular
directions but in terms of sort of a big
theory of how that works we don't really
have that there are sort of potential
poke this and you might be able to sort
of reverse the clock because we're sort
of understanding there's an inexorable
biological clock and uh you know for
example the kinds of things that were
discovered what a decade ago or
something now to uh go back go from any
cell you have back to a stem cell that's
capable of differentiating into any
other type of cell the things that one
can kind of use to do that maybe those
things are things that can sort of reset
the clock for for aging one doesn't know
yet but there are potential
breakthroughs that could happen along
those lines um where it's like I mean
that would be a really cool thing if it
ever happen sort of the elixir of
Eternal youth type thing it's just like
here's this thing and oh well the way
biology evolved and because in fact in
evolution the fact that the old fogies
die off is probably a good thing for the
species so it's something that will be
selected for in biological evolution
even if the sort of uh immortality might
be cool for the individual at least in
the course of of in the past it's been
sort of bad for the species and maybe
it's even bad for the species now maybe
if we if we reach human immortality
nothing new will ever happen in the
world because everybody will say well
this is is how I've been doing it for
6,000 years and uh you know really I'm
I'm happy doing that I don't want to
change anything it's always a
complicated thing you know the fact that
um uh it's often this when something is
sort of successful and lasts a long time
and so on and everybody thinks that's a
big success it it sort of builds inertia
that makes it more difficult for
something new and different to happen so
it's it's always a a complicated
multiply edged sword and it certainly
I'm sure it has been for biological
evolution but you know that that's
obviously a a dramatic breakthrough that
I don't think we can know when it will
happen or whether it's even possible uh
you know it could be that it's like you
know an operating system for a computer
which sort of gradually develops more
and more kind of cruff and eventually it
crashes and you have to restart your
computer and maybe that's sort of an
inexorable feature of systems like that
and and Like Us in biology so to speak
there are other things like cryonics is
one thing that I could have imagine at
some moment it will just be solved just
like mamalian cloning was at one moment
just solved uh that that some kind of oh
if you do this and you tweak things in
this way and you give the electric shock
at just the right moment then you can
clone uh mammals I could imagine the
same kind of thing in terms of cryonics
being able to kind of Hit the pause
button for for human life type thing but
um uh let's see other area where there
might be dramatic progress I mean I
think um
uh there are there are always things
that are sort of out there like um
molecular scale Computing which is very
similar to molecular biology and
possibly related to all these questions
about theories of bulk orchestration and
so on but possibly a little different
it's like how do you make that Universal
Constructor that was a big Topic in the
1980s really died off of can you make a
thing that will just start assembling
things out of atoms and you know we can
do that with an atomic Force microscope
we can pick up a few atoms and put them
in definite places but that's not a a
thing that scales up very well can you
make something where you just feed it
the plans and it just goes off and it
spends you know a few hours and it's
just gradually much like protein
synthesis happens in biology it's just
steadily making a thing out of carbon
atoms for example eventually it will be
figured out how to do that and and that
will probably be and once you have a
universal Constructor like that the
universal Constructor can clearly
construct more Universal Constructors
and it's kind of off and running and
that that kind of notion of doing that
is something people have talked about
since the
1940s um and as I say it got a bit
popular in the 19 in the early 1980s and
then died off kind of absorbed into some
combination of chemistry and Material
Science which went off in rather
different
directions what other things might be
coming well you know there's there's
there's always the unexpected I mean if
we look at different areas of whether
it's in in medicine and oh did you know
that if you just do this you solve this
big problem for example to um an area
well like physics where there's a
question of why do things work in this
particular way or we can finally find
this theory that underlies that and
explains how things go on I'm trying to
think what other are is uh um if people
want to ask about them I'm happy to to
talk about them um I think uh uh you
know there are areas that will show sort
of slow engineering progress like a lot
of AI kinds of things I think yeah
another area that is sort of a a a
question is sort of will AI magically
solve
science uh I think the answer is no um I
think that there are sort of what does
that even mean
you know will it be the case that there
is sort of a transformation in the way
that certain kinds of science are done I
don't think so I think that a lot of
what we see in terms of just search some
big space of
possibilities that's much more of a
traditional computational problem than
it is a more aiish problem things like
read the literature see whether there's
something that you can pull together
from all these different little little
threads and shreds in the literature
that gives you some definite thing we've
already been able to do a surprising
amount of that just searching the
literature I mean even even before the
web you know one could search uh there
were online database systems that would
search uh the abstracts of all
scientific papers things like this so
that's been a sort of a slow a slow
progression I don't expect to see
something where it's like uh uh
particularly dramatic there will be
things that are yes it's very useful one
can do this and that but I don't think
it will be kind of a a a wow
breakthrough kind of
thing I think uh uh there are probably
well there are
things
where I I think the real question is
what are the old chestnuts and which
ones might be cracked whatever one does
um uh in in short order and I think you
know two of the big methods that have
emerged and that's always what let's one
crack old problems as new methods two
methods one is the llm story the other
is the story of things that have emerged
from our physics project those are two
sort of big methodological things I
think that have emerged in the last uh
few years and they certainly have uh
neither of them has has been fully
worked through the loow hanging fruit
still has to be picked and on a time
scale of order a year I think in both
those cases there's a bunch of
scientific lwh hang fruit to be to be
picked let's
see
uh question here about
graphine from
Giovani
um you know graphine is one of the
strange things you can make just out of
carbon atoms you know people used to
think oh the only things you can make
out of out of carbon
were uh you know pure carbon were
diamond and graphite um and then Bucky
Balls were discovered these kind of
clusters of 60 carbon atoms and more the
remarkable thing about Bucky Balls is
they've always been there they've been
in Su forever they just hadn't been
identified and it's sort of an
interesting like many science
discoveries it's kind of a thing where
it was hiding in plain sight for a long
time graphine is kind of the tubular
version of um of a bucky ball and yes
there are you know what what's great
about it it has high electrical
conductivity it is is something from
which you can make electric circuits
people have slowly started to make
transistor like things out of it um I am
not on a on a sort of a month-by-month
basis or even year-by-year basis I I
don't know what the latest developments
have been there my impression has been
that it's going to be a slow progression
of of adding more sort of engineering
possibilities to what can be done with
graphine I mean people talk about yes it
can be a very strong material you could
make a you know a space elevator out of
it maybe possibly um you could make
electric circuits that have all sorts of
special properties out of it um these
are things which are I my impression is
they're in the slow engineering
development improve the technology type
phase they weren't blocked in any way
but they also weren't uh uh weren't like
um uh you know that're they're not at
the stage where major breakthrough is
needed they're more at the stage of
engineering development
I I would say another area in the same
situation is probably fusion power um
where it's like can you build a toac can
you figure out can you build this
magnetic confinement mechanism for the
for the you know 10 million degrees
Centigrade plasma that um has energetic
enough particles that they'll undergo
fusion um can you contain the thing even
if you can contain it with some kind of
big magnetic field bottle um if it
starts showing fusion and starts
generating Lots of high energy neutrons
for example even the things that
generate the magnetic field the magnets
will they just be destroyed by the
neutrons and is it kind of game over at
that point uh these are
engineering efforts that um uh really
are sort of the you know typically what
happens methodological Advance rapid
progress then sometimes there are things
which just need a lot of engineering
grinding over the course of decades to
take them from yes it's in principle
Poss possible to it's routinely
doable
uh gosh Erin asks about bio vehicles
with um uh synthetic adapost tissue I do
not know about that um I think the the
possibility of sort of a breakthrough in
electrochemistry of you know lithium ion
was sort of a breakthrough long ago but
the possibility of a different chemistry
that will be a breakthrough is I think
there's nothing to say that's impossible
there's nothing to say it's impossible
to find a substance which will be
provide photovoltaic performance that's
vastly higher than than silicon does now
um and uh these are things where sort of
searching for materials it's like like
the the quintessential Edison searching
for the filament which ended up being in
his case carbon for the light bulb um
you know when people have tried for
decades es sort of just search molecular
space for things that are good for you
can name them good
photovoltaics uh good sup high
temperature
superconductors um potentially things
for Batteries although those have been a
little bit less less systematically
searched for and the big one drugs uh
searching for molecules which have
particular biological
effects all of these efforts have been
sort of partially successful people are
always saying I'm going to use AI to
just win every win every battle there
it's never happened I don't think it
will happen as such I think it's just a
a slow steady progress with occasional
wow we found something unexpected I mean
in my own efforts in sort of studying
the computational universe of possible
programs there's this occasional moment
where you find something totally
unexpected and where it's a a major
piece of progress um and I think that
could certainly happen in the in the
sort of material world molecules and so
on um although it hasn't been a thing
that's been sort of big dramatic success
there are now well there there have been
for many years a whole sort of rotating
series of companies that have grown up
saying now we're going to be able to do
rational drug design comor chemistry uh
sort of AI based chemical Discovery
molecular Discovery uh you know
incremental progress but not drama at
this point um
let's see and in terms of you know
different Technologies for batteries I
don't know could happen you know what
always is the case is that you get a
dramatic new idea for some technology
and then there's an incumbent technology
and the incumbent technology has had a
lot of engineering development 50 years
let's say of engineering development and
often it's actually pretty rare that the
new entrance is immediately better than
the old one you know I I don't uh oh
when when transistors came in vacuum
tubes have been developed for many years
many decades and I don't think there was
an immediate oh yeah transistors
everywhere there were places where
transistors made an inroad and then
microprocessors got developed and so on
but you know when you've got something
where there's been a big long uh sort of
period of of detailed development that
usually initially wins out you might see
that the transistors are on a much more
rapid slope and they're going to take
over but it's still doesn't happen
immediately and you know it's always a
big surprise when something happens like
Chachi BT where that was sort of so much
better that it sort of was an immediate
thing uh I would like to say that things
like wolf malfa have have served in the
same way of being sort of there was
there was what was before it in those
directions was very weak
and then it was able to deliver
something uh surprisingly strong in in
2009 in that case but you know that's I
would say a lot of the time things that
have had extensive engineering
development the the new entrant doesn't
immediately win big and you really have
to sort of watch the curve to understand
that it's the thing that's going to
win I think that's a um uh you see that
for example with our comp ational
language sort of which is now 35 years
old um and although uh you know greatly
developed over that period of time but
you know you can kind of see that that
gradually takes over different areas and
different kinds of things one thinks
about as compared to for example
lowlevel programming languages and but
that's a slow long complicated thing to
sort of uh uh relative to the the the
development that's been done on on
lowlevel programming languages and and
particularly in that case the kind of uh
uh the the the sort of the incumbent
knowledge about those kinds of things
and beliefs about those kinds of
things let's
see
uh pav is
asking
um do I think the traditional
engineering disciplines will be
relegated to some kind of L
uh you know will they be automated with
llms you know the story of many things
I've tried to do is automate what used
to require a lots of human effort
whether that's calculating integrals in
math whether that's solving lots of
kinds of computational problems uh
automation is one of the big drivers of
progress and yes there'll be lots
there'll be more of that will it be
dramatic and sudden and now we can
suddenly solvable engineering uh just by
pushing an AI button I don't think so I
think
that what will happen is that the the
sort of the the things will just
gradually rise it's kind of a rising
tide of possibilities and what becomes
possible to design becomes possible to
do gets ever more complicated and that
will allow one to be ever more ambitious
I mean as computerated design
computerated engineering have come in
the complexity of the devices that one
can build has vastly increased
the the actual challenge of building
them remains sort of a fixed challenge
of what people can figure out how to do
and how to define and so on but what
actually gets built is much bigger
because of that layer of
automation let's see UNS supervision
asks do you think we'll see Mass
producible room temperature
superconductors in the next decade I do
not know uh you know nobody's being able
to make a room temperature
superconductor um is it theoretically
impossible absolutely not there is
nothing that says it's theoretically
impossible um what material might make
it possible we don't know you know it's
kind of every so often somebody will
come up with some exotic material that
involves you know pieces of lanthanum or
pieces of whatever else I forget what
was it was a recent one what was that
one um oh I don't remember it used a
rare earth metal of some kind that was a
bit exotic and one hadn't heard much of
wasn't h on it was something like that
um and you know there is a lot of
chemical space molecular space that is
unexplored and that's where the
opportunities exist to find sort of
surprising things like robust room
temperature superconductors if there
were robust room temperature
superconductors there's a vast range of
technology that becomes possible but we
don't have them and we you know we we we
don't know how to make
those so douge is asking uh it's been
suggested AI will replace coders and
programmers do you think AI might also
replace many physical and chemical
experiments interesting question I was
uh uh our longtime kind of Partners at
Emerald Cloud lab who've been building
this Big W language based uh sort of lab
in the cloud that sort of robotically
does experiments that you specify in
computational language uh that's an
interesting question whether you
actually need to do the experiments the
answer right now is a definitive and
resounding yes the fact that you can do
the experiments and this is something
that I think will be uh sort of this
concept of cloud labs and so on will I
think be quite a practical breakthrough
in doing biology chemistry and so on
experiments that instead of sort of
everybody has to build up their lab and
spend a year building a new lab and so
on you can just use the cloud lab and
just type in the specification of what
you want to have happened and the thing
is already set up it's kind of like
cloud computing you don't have to build
your own servers but building your own
servers is a lot lot lot easier than
building your own biology or chemistry
lab and so I think that is a practical
matter of what is possible to do in
biology and chemistry and so and
research that is a potentially a major
driver of progress it also has another
feature which is you sort of you have a
born reproducible experiment it's like
here's the script just run it again
again it better do the same thing it
also gives you kind of a a formal
description language the fact that such
a script exists and can run those
physical experiments gives you a formal
description language for for experiments
which is very useful in kind of
understanding well I take this
experiment I tweak it a bit I take this
experiment I rerun it Etc the question
of whether you actually need to run the
experiments in the end right now the
answer is very much yes interesting
question can you take many runs of those
experiments and kind of machine learn
how the experiments work the answer is
probably somewhat how far that will get
I'm not sure I think it will be hard to
find surprises that way I think what
machine learning is good at doing is
kind of you know fitting things the way
that they sort of naturally go together
which means if there's a big sort of
poke out surprise you don't tend to see
it you do see that if you do things like
exhaustively search all possibilities
then one of those possib ities ends up
being the thing you never thought what
it was going to do and it does something
really surprising but machine learning
tends to be a thing that kind of
smoothly interpolates between what's
already known and it doesn't notice
these sort of big spikes that poke
out uh there's a question here from prab
about zero knowledge
proofs so I do think that's an area
where they're probably will be progress
made I mean in in cryptography was a
rather obscure thing back in the even
the beginning of the 1980s was sort of
oh yeah it's this thing that gets done
but it isn't really a a thing that's
sort of in the public Consciousness very
much and then as the web developed and
things like this cryptography became
important and big but public key
cryptography had come on the scene the
ability to uh do things like make
digital signatures the ability to
publish a a cryptographic key that
allows people to send you data um but
doesn't allows only you to decode the
data and then there's a vast number of
protocols that have been developed based
on that like the https protocol for
validating websites or the the um uh
protocols for digital money all these
kinds of things these are all protocols
that became possible because of public
key cryptography now one of the big
questions is to what extent can you uh
take data encrypt the data so nobody can
find the whole thing but sort of poke at
the data and ask specific questions and
uh and get those question questions
answered without having to decode all
the data so for example let's say you
have a bunch of medical test results for
lots of different people and you doing a
study where you just want to know does
everybody who uh you know gets some oh I
don't know does everybody
who gets flu have a um uh you know is
there higher probability of them getting
this other thing sometime later or
whatever else I don't know what and that
might exist in all these medical records
but it's for privacy reasons one's not
going to reveal everything that's in
these medical records but if you could
have all the medical records encrypted
but just be able to poke at them and say
just give me this one fact across 10,000
different Medical Records I don't want
to know anybody's individual results I
just want to know the aggregate
distribution of whether people got sick
or whatever else it is and can one do
that is there a a way of doing that the
common buzzword is fully homomorphic
encryption of of whether you can kind of
whether you can exchange the operation
of encryption and the operation of
computing something whether you can
compute sort of through the encryption
so to speak without having to decrypt
first make a plain version then do the
computation so there's been slow
progress of this it is theoretical
you know there are theoretical results
there are a few uh you know there's Buzz
terms for this there's a little bit of
work that's been done particularly in
the blockchain space on zero knowledge
ZK snarks and things like this there's
just a a whole collection of of uh
mathematically quite sophisticated
things you can find nice wor and
language implementations of a bunch of
these things um there are uh I think
there are sort of two directions one is
making those algorithms more practical
and the other is figuring out protocols
that can make use of these things I mean
it's worth remembering that with public
key cryptography one might have said oh
this is never going to go anywhere it's
too difficult to encrypt megabytes of
data with public key cryptography but
that turns out not to be necessary all
you need to do is deal with the the sort
of distribution of keys using public key
cryptography and once you've got the key
you can use a more traditional Cipher to
to do the encryption or decryption but
the protocol exists to know how to do
this key exchange um using using public
key cryptography and Achieve certain
sort of objectives in terms of the way
that secrecy is maintained and so on and
I I think that's an area where there
there will be progress an acable
progress there might be some
breakthroughs there will be a a higher I
was just trying to remember in in the
last probably few months I've seen at
least a few products that rely on zero
knowledge uh systems um and uh they're
not yet practical out there in the field
I think those particular products but
the fact that there are products
starting to be developed that rely on
these ideas I think is
interesting
um Juan is asking given some of our
greatest accomplishments as species have
been when we mimic nature how important
do you think biomatics is in going
forward you know there are meta lessons
of biology like natural selection we do
natural selection on our technology as
happens in biology so to speak we learn
things at a sort of meta level then we
learn things at a much more detailed
level like oh can we make uh uh can we
create molecules that have this
particular feature because look biology
does something like that do we end up
using you know there was a push for a
while to do sort of DNA based Computing
I don't think that's really panned out
for a whole variety of reasons but
that's kind of like take what biology
has already figured out about DNA and
and leverage that to build a kind of
technolog Technology stack on top of it
I think the um
it's I think some of these cases where
people say oh we're going to imitate you
know the eye of the uh of the of the
horseshoe crab or something to do this
or that thing those tend to be more in
the nature of sort of inspiration about
how things could work than a detail
that's going measure horseshoe crabs to
see what we should do um have we mined
everything we can m in biology
definitely not there's a huge amount of
molecular biology where we don't
understand the mechanisms yet and where
when we do understand them we have the
chance to kind of make our own versions
of them when it comes to large scale
biology and kind of uh uh I don't know
how we might make robot arms based on
the you know the the bones and muscles
and tendons and so on of of our sort of
biological construction I would say
we're a decent distance of the way
through mining that knowledge but
there's plenty of biological knowledge
we just don't have but we haven't been
able to mine
yet carille asks you see a time when the
discovery of new mathematical theorems
and axioms will be generated from AIS
it's an interesting question looked at
it a whole bunch uh the real thing is
it's pretty easy to generate infinite
numbers of mathematical theorems given a
certain set of a you just keep applying
them you generate this big entailment
cone one might call it of things
entailed from those axioms the real
question is of all these theorems most
of them when you look at them you just
kind of roll your eyes you say I don't
know why I'd care about that so there's
this question of what constitutes a
theorem one should care about an
interesting theorem can one for example
machine learn what we humans have
traditionally thought of as interesting
can we pick out the interesting theorems
and in some automated way I think that's
not hopeless we've tried to do it a
bunch and we haven't been very
successful at it I don't think that's
abjectly
hopeless um there is a sense in which
interestingness is determined by history
and in which kind of something is
interesting if it was studied
historically and led to this and led to
that and has a certain context that
people understand that's a way in which
uh uh that's sort of a a generator of
interestingness which in a sense it has
to be lived by the human mathematicians
in order for it to be interesting in
that kind of Direction it doesn't it
isn't good enough to say oh the ai's
discovered this um the the human
mathematicians are just going to shrug
and say we don't care because in order
for us to Care in order for us to quotes
understand this in a way that sort of uh
merges with the things we already know
we have to sort of pull it into our our
sort of actual experience so to
speak so I think this question of
whether whether machine
whether an AI can sort of pick out
attributes that it's noticed from the
few million theorems that humans have
published in the literature of
mathematics it's noticed humans tend to
like this let me make it work like that
it's kind of like image generation
systems where some of them have been
trained to be make pictures that are
attractive to humans and yes they can do
that to some extent and you know make
theorems that are attractive and
interesting to
humans now when it comes to axioms
that's a much more complicated assume
because axioms are sort of what you
assume is true and you're they going to
build up from but the question is how do
you pick axioms not very many have been
conventionally picked in mathematics
that things like the axum of piano
arithmetic the axum of set theory the
axum of geometry there are small list of
these axim that have been picked for the
progression of mathematics as it has
existed to today when I wrote my book A
New Kind of Science I decided to put on
actually ended up being two pages all
the axioms of mathematics as currently
practiced including actually some other
quite obscure ones they all fit in those
two pages admittedly in a rather small
font but so the question then is okay
well so are we going to have new
axioms well usually the way those axioms
were derived was here are some things we
think are true either intuitively think
are true or well just we think are true
you know a point has no extent an a
essentially an axium of uclid um the uh
you know two parallel lines never meet
an axiim of uclid that turned out not to
be true about physical space but these
are things where you go from sort of
your common experience or the things
that you think of being wanting to be
true then you make up aims then you say
well what else is entailed by those
things that I've assumed are true so I
think it's very difficult to say you
know except in so far as one sort of
capturing what humans have typically
thought of as true then that's um uh
that that's kind of the uh the best we
can think of to do to sort of go back
there's sort of the idea reverse
mathematics given that you have a
particular theorem that you want to be
true what are the minimal axioms that
give you that theorem well in a sense
that's what we've been practicing and
coming up with the the aims that we've
already come up with which then get
encrusted with huge amounts of history
and huge numbers of things built on top
of them I mean it's kind of like in an
economic system you invent a thing like
Bitcoin for example and is it worth
anything well as soon as you build
enough stuff in the world this whole
network of consequences and entailments
and so on then it becomes somehow a real
thing with real value and the same is is
perhaps true with mathematical axioms
that you know I just invent an axiom
it's like okay fine I don't know you
know you've got a circle operator in
there and it does this and that you kind
of shrug your shoulders it's kind of
like so what um but then if it turns out
that on top of that is built this whole
collection of kind of thinking about
Computing or or mathematics or whatever
else then that becomes something that
has more of a a sort of real intrinsic
value to
it Aaron
asks when blees explodes will humans be
okay uh Bal is a red giant star fairly
close to us that will have a lifetime of
a few million years um and eventually it
will turn into a supernova and explode
um
I think the answer to that I I think if
there was a I think the answer is yes um
I think we'll get to see this very
bright spot in the sky um that'll last
for at least a few days I think that the
particles that will come will stream out
from the Supernova I'm not sure we know
exactly how many such particles there
are we have probably some information um
I remember reading something about this
recently and um uh I think you know
given that we given the Earth's
atmosphere and given that there aren't
so many particles that the atmosphere
gets destroyed which will be bad news
for us um I I think I think we get to be
okay
uh but um that is a detailed question I
think some of some of what is some of
what is to be said about that you know
when you see a supernova explosion um
you certainly see things that have been
I I actually don't know what the um uh
the density of of high high energy
particles from a supernova explosion
would be and uh you know are there lots
of um
um uh for example are
there what actually happens there there
there'll probably be high energy protons
high energy electrons there are high
energy protons from the Sun that's the
dominant component of cosmic rays that
hit the earth they make auroras things
like this when the when the high energy
particles um are sort of Trapped By the
magnetic field of the earth and interact
with the molecules in the upper
atmosphere um I don't know how much more
intense kind of uh the the effectively
cosmic ray uh flux
from the Supernova at the distance of
balers
is relative to what we what we encounter
all the time from the Sun is it like a
big solar flare is it like a small solar
flare um or is it like something we've
never seen before that will cause much
more trouble I actually don't know uh
good
question uh weasel asks you think smart
textiles and Computing Fabrics will take
off or be viable would I wear a sweater
to hear instead of a hearing aid you
know there are always these things which
people sort of say hey I got this cool
thing from the future look it's a a
smart coat or something there're things
which are constantly from the future and
eventually arrive most things constantly
from the future eventually do arrive and
uh sometimes in a form slightly
different than they were originally
imagined but the idea of smart clothing
where uh sort of it does things um I
don't know the the you know the
billboard t-shirt so to speak that's
continually changing what what it
displays and so on the uh the sort of
the thing where don't wear a smartwatch
just uh you know your your shirt sleeve
will will have that um uh will be sort
of uh able to do the health monitoring
and and so on that that was able to do
um my guess is eventually those things
will will take off um eventually
there'll be electronics that is uh
sufficiently low power it can be powered
from body heat and things like this
eventually there'll be sort of I mean
I've seen lots of samples of of various
kinds of flexible electronics and and
this and that and the other so my guess
is that the the general principle is
what was having to be made in very
well-controlled Electronics will be able
to be made in many different media in
the future what the big use cases will
be I'm not quite sure um and uh uh yeah
it's an interesting interesting
question
um let's see Wyatt comments things like
math geometry especially tessellations
have patterns that are universally
implicit and can be interpreted to be
interesting by their own existence and
not just by Humanity viewing
them well it's pretty hard for us to
ascend sort of transcend our own history
I think you know of the what's interest
in question you know I think that I've
sort of lived that because I've studied
a lot what's possible in the kind of
computational Universe of possible
programs and so on and much of what one
sees there is uh kind of um lots of
interesting complicated forms where we
ask you know is this significant is it
not significant it's hard to say it's uh
you know it's a thing one discovers it's
just like you go out in nature you find
some weird creature living under some
rock somewhere and it has some
complicated mechanism going on in it is
this interesting or is it just the weird
feature of the such and such Beetle hard
to know and I think I think it's very
difficult to know what we're going what
we're going to care about in the future
is not necessarily what we care about
today an example I've given many times
is n fractal patterns which were created
well they were created by nature but
they were created by humans by Mosaic
layers in the beginning of the
1200s and nobody cared for nearly 800
years until the kind of whole context of
fractals and nesting and and so on emerg
basically in the 1970s and then people
are like oh that's a fractal pattern
that's cool so fractal patterns are to
us today you know a sapinsky pattern or
something to today that's kind of
self-evident to us in the 1200s people
you know a particular person I think his
name was Cosmo cosmati invented this and
knew about it and probably thought it
was really cool and nobody else cared
and I think that is the what causes
people to care about something is a
complicated issue that is very
historically uh related and I think
that's I think you really can't say
abstractly things like tessellation
patterns are going to be cool to
everybody I I would say that you know
features of numbers you could say are
cool to everybody but but you know for
example the pythagoreans were as
enthusiastic about perfect numbers as
they were about about primes as it turns
out primes have been much more important
in the history of mathematics as it is
actually developed than than perfect
numbers have been but I don't think one
could say that as an abstract
matter
um but I mean this whole question about
what is
interesting you know the theory of
interestingness and you know is is the
nested pattern is this particular
geometrical pattern actually interesting
question I don't know do chimpanzees
find uh sort of tiling patterns engaging
and interesting do they can they readily
predict how the pattern will continue my
guess is yes um if you feed them nested
patterns can they readily predict how
those work I'm not so sure about that
and then what about other kinds of
animals you know can you I don't know
how you do the experiment with dogs or
something but I bet there is a way to do
it of uh kind of you know the the do
they expect the tiling to go on this way
do they find the tiling preferable to
the kind of random Arrangement and so on
I don't think um uh um I think that's a
um uh you know those are those are those
are difficult to answer questions it's
very difficult I've been very interested
in this question about how do we
transcend our own history and our own
detailed features to see what is sort of
intellectually possible beyond that hard
to
do
um let's
see Juan asks is there a way we can use
Brown and motion of molecular scale is a
type of fingerprint for nanosensors to
create things that are piracy proof yeah
I mean there's a whole movement of
so-called physically unique functions
Puffs which are kind of when you make a
semiconductor device the details of
where the molecules were moving around
right at the moment when that cicon
piece of silicon crystal uh was formed
can matter and so you can end up with
these things where where you have a
physically unique object and sometimes
you can even end up with a pair of
physically unique objects like for
example our fingerprints you know they
kind of agree on the two sides because
because they were formed together so to
speak and so you can have similar of
things where you form something together
I mean this was a thing used gosh it's
not new technology this was used in um
uh back in certainly the Middle Ages and
possibly before people would take a
thing a stick or something else they'd
break it and one person would get one
half one person got the other half do
they match you know that was kind of
that's kind of like this physical unique
functions idea and that is a thing that
seems to have been slowly gaining in
popularity and I think there may be some
some sort of sign ific pieces of
technology that you built that way it's
kind of a a physically physical source
of of um of burnt in Randomness now the
question of brown in motion which is
continually happening I there one thing
when something gets a solid thing gets
formed that has a particular shape or
particular electrical properties it's
another thing when one's actually using
the continual randomness of things like
Bound in motion molecular motion and so
on yes you can use that to generate in
fact it's it's a routine thing in most
microprocessors there is an instruction
that just says pick up some noise from
the environment and make a bit based on
that pick up some thermal noise from a a
transistor Junction type thing and use
that to generate a bit so in a sense you
know as you try and generate those bits
very quickly you have to have sort of
the heat has to diffuse into the place
where you're generating those bits for
them to be sort of independent but yes
the idea that you can kind of have a a
Randomness antenna picking up heat from
the environment to get your local
Randomness that's a thing and that's
even a thing in in existing technology
uh I think as protocols get developed
there will need to be more you know
whether it's physically unique functions
or something else that will drive the
need for other kinds of Randomness
generation and so
on let's see wish is asking why are the
a of mathematics are necessarily the
ones that are effective at describing
things we
see well because we made
mathematics as a way of understanding
for ourselves things we are seeing we
didn't make
mathematics for the things that are
computationally possible for example
I've studied quite a bit this question
of what's computationally possible and
what we can then say about that but
that's what's computationally possible
is much broader than what we have
identified and thought worth capturing
in our
mathematics
let's
see rul is asking what do things like
dreams and higher States Of
Consciousness talked about in eastern
philosophy tell us about ourselves as
observers probably quite a bit I mean I
think it's pretty interesting and people
have been writing to me quite a bit
about this that kind of some of the
things that we really are finding from a
science point of view and the ruad and
observer Theory and so on really are
converging in many ways with things that
people have talked about in eastern
philosophy and and other kinds of areas
like that you know I think it's a
general principle that sometimes a
little bit hard for people to swallow
that by the time something has been
talked about enough and and it's gotten
enough Traction in the world there's
probably something to it it may not be
it may be a thing that is you know the
something is not what you thought it was
and when you interpret it in your way
the thing that's important to you is
different from the thing that was
important before but I think by the time
there's as much talk as there there is
about kind of Eastern philosophy you
know
spiritual type type things and so on
there's something to it it's not just oh
it's all nonsense it just got crushed by
science ignore it it's like you know and
gradually we're starting to see things
which people have have said in in ways
that sounded very unscientific from a
western science point of view we're
we're we're finally being able to make
this bridge from Western science to many
of these kinds of of discussions
and I think some of them uh somebody
like me for example is somewhat
challenged in the fact that I don't have
good sort of intuition about let's say
Eastern philosophy and traditions around
that or you know I'm not the um uh the
sort of alternate States Of
Consciousness uh you know I'm a person
who to give a too much personal
information doesn't remember dreams very
much so I don't you know I don't have a
big intuition base from those kinds of
things so so it's uh uh you know most of
my I have intuition based from things
like studying the computational universe
which sadly not as many people as should
have done have done that's given me all
kinds of intuition that's led me into
all kinds of interesting things
including these areas that sort of
connect with kind of Eastern philosophy
and so on but it's uh it's challenging
to you know there's a big Corpus of
knowledge but it's not kind of
traditional Western Scientific style
knowledge it's a different kind of
knowledge and how one sort of merges
that with the scientific is is you know
it's a challenge but I think I think
we've reached a point in the science
where that linkage is possible although
part of that linkage has to come from
people who have sort of an intrinsic
intuition for those kinds of things and
you know I know whenever I enter some
new area it's kind of always challenging
to get the intrinsic intuition of that
area what's plausible what's not I mean
a great example of this is uh if you are
used to physics
and then you think about biom medicine
in physics we get nailed down answers
it's just like this is how it works it's
this Theory there these rules there's
this equation we can solve it boom it
works in biom medicine things are always
complicated it's always oh there's
always another effect there's always a
little thing oh in 0.1% of the
population this will happen because this
particular genomic thing is different or
whatever else it's it's there's this
infinite tale of sort of complexity of
how things work which is not the way it
is in in physics for example so those
intuitions are different and if you try
and apply one to the other you end up
getting confused and so that's that's
sort of a challenging thing to get to
the point where you have that that kind
of
intuition
um let's see Stefan asks would it be
easy to have I think mean an AI remaster
old movies real ones and cartoons so we
can watch all the old gems in high-end
Graphics you know people are already
doing that um I haven't seen this will
be a fun thing I haven't seen cartoon to
live action I'm sure that will come I
mean that seems quite doable uh you know
there's always the question of when you
do kind of the AI rendering at the first
look it's like wow that's amazing when
you look in more detail it's often a
little bit flat a little bit Bal a
little bit kind of reversion to the mean
kind of thing I don't know if that will
continue or whether it's whether it's a
question of of sort of being able to
make it more ergonomic for humans to
pull it out in a slightly more creative
Direction you know does it um uh you
know the the um if you're kind of taking
um uh I don't know pick your cartoon
series I'm going to show my age by
picking I don't know Tom and Jerry was a
cat and a mouse you know is there a
liveaction version of that well there
might be some you know if you have a
little creative flare
the mouse might have a a TFT of some
different colored hair or something that
wasn't that would be part of the sort of
creative flare but wouldn't be even
visible in the original kind of cartoon
version but yeah I think that's a that's
a thing we can fully
expect
uh let's see Cosmic is commenting
interesting is defined by coolness
threshold yeah okay well then we have
the question of what's cool and how much
is is that societal and how much do you
need to know how many social media likes
you get to know whether it's cool and
how much can you know that it's you know
intrinsically know it's cool my guess is
it's it's you have to know the likes now
you know a thing people have long been
interested in this can you predict given
this YouTube video will it go viral or
not I've seen people try and use
actually our technology stack a bunch to
make predictions along those lines you
know should we invest in these YouTube
videos because they're going to go viral
should we that that's one version of it
another version of it is what attributes
you know if we weren't going to make a
topic for a viral video or a meme or
whatever else you know what what
attributes should that have so it has
the best chance of going viral and yes
there's a certain amount of sort of uh
uh of analysis that AIS can give about
those kinds of things um and uh uh you
know it's all complicated because as
soon as things are sort of routinely AI
assisted it kind of raises the the level
for everything and means that for it to
be interesting you kind of like oh yeah
I've seen lots of those before if it's
interesting it's going to be the next
level up so to
speak uh prz
comments since the scientific Paradigm
is a major cause for the enlightenment
can we expect computational Paradigm
multicomp computational Paradigm to kick
off a soop philosophical Paradigm of
comparable importance
I think yes I think that the kind of the
idea that there was science that there
were intellectual things you could just
figure out about the world that was sort
of the story of the Enlightenment and
that it wasn't all just what was written
in a book from a couple thousand years
earlier it was um whether Aristotle or
the Bible um it was um uh it was kind
of the the concept that new knowledge
was derivable that science could say
things and then into the middle of that
came things like cernic ISM where you
know the question of whether the earth
goes around the Sun or the Sun goes
around the earth it's not an everyday
issue people don't care about that on an
everyday basis but what's important
about it was the fact that that got
established that the science gives you
an answer to something which Common
Sense does not give you common sense
says the Earth is standing still Common
Sense doesn't say the Earth is moving at
a high speed around the Sun but yet the
science said that and the science in
some sense was right and I think that's
that was kind of a sort of an
important kind of thing that cemented
this idea that kind of you could invent
new knowledge and the new knowledge
would be meaningful and so I think in as
we see kind of computation multicomp
computation coming in as a paradigm for
thinking about things yes there's
there's sort of a huge amount that uh
could be could be different I mean for
example I think one of the things that's
been a post-industrial revolution
phenomenon is the am I expected to
understand this question we expect to
understand technology at some level at
least we expect we're surprised we're
disappointed if we don't know why it
works how it works because we built
technology that mostly is understandable
yet what we're learning from
computational irreducibility for example
is that if we want to take advantage of
comput utation that won't always be
what's possible that we will have to
deal with technology that we
fundamentally don't understand we only
know certain attributes that it has but
you know it's it's a very interesting
question what can be you know given the
computational Paradigm what will be sort
of the big takeaways from it I think one
of them is there stuff you can
understand there's stuff you can't
understand there's stuff you can kind of
regulate there's stuff you can't
regulate the kind of concept of the
science-based you know controlled
culture Society etc etc etc we kind of
learn from the computational Paradigm
that's just not going to work it's uh uh
it's it's just not a thing that's
possible it's only possible if you
constrain yourself in this very narrow
way in which which a lot of existing
science and engineering have done and
have been able to build a lot from that
but if we really want to take advantage
of computation as a power so to speak we
we don't get to be able to always
predict what will happen you know I
think that um
uh that's
so you know knowing what the
consequences of computation
computational reducibility and so will
be I have to say when I came up with
kind of the idea of computational
irreducibility in the early
1980s the idea that that notion would
turn into things like proof of work for
blockchain had no idea of that no idea
that that you know that there would be
this sort of thing that is basically
computational irreducibility would be
the thing where people are you know
burning the electric power output of a
small country or at least have done in
the past to you know mine Bitcoin by
sort of grinding their way into
computational irreducibility that was
not something from the scientific idea
that was at all readily foreseeable I
think the the very notion of kind of the
the sort of the modern conceit that we
can figure out everything which was the
you know a couple hundred years later a
few hundred years later consequence of
kind of the success of the scientific
Paradigm that led to many changes in our
way of thinking about life and
everything and I think the the
realization now that computational
irreducibility means we can't know
everything leads to kind of a a little
bit of a you know a pivoting back to
something where it's more like things
just happen happen now with the whole
sort of multicomp computation story and
the way in which we kind of extract
narrative theories like the fundamental
theories of physics from this
computationally irreducible underlying
stuff it's kind of knowing what's
knowable knowing realizing that there
are things that are knowable but there's
a lot that isn't and being able to
identify what's knowable and what's not
is probably an important direction for
the future I mean you know it could be
the case that in biom medicine there are
things that we want to know and they're
computationally irreducible and we can't
know them it could be but it could be
that if we sort of architect certain
kinds of things differently like let's
say in economics it could be that there
are things in economics where we
actually want computational reducibility
we want things to be unpredictable if
the stock market was completely
predictable many aspects of it wouldn't
work it would be uh kind of um uh it
would be there would be if it was all
predictable everything would sort of
move move together in a very brittle way
the fact that there's this Randomness in
the market is what leads to kind of a a
robustness that is uh that that lets it
be in some sense stable and I think uh
but you know what is it there that can
be identified as a form of regularity
for example the idea that there's a
notion of price as opposed to just every
transaction has to be a v transaction
that is a a consequence of some kind of
higher level description that you can
give
so I think that's some uh um a few
thoughts there but it's it's an
interesting question and I I actually
probably deserves more thinking on my
part although it's it's if you're
interested in sort of you know
anticipating the future this is a
particularly far reach in terms of going
from kind of a conceptual idea like
computation multicomp putation and so on
to what its consequences will be I don't
think you know Alan Turing 1936
inventing cing machines the idea that
word processors and so on will be a
popular use of computers was far far
away from what could have been imagine
and part of the reason there was that in
alanan day even in the days of early
computers it's like computers are
expensive and you know what can we do
with them well you know we have to have
something that's really worth doing you
know worth using a computer on as i'
think I've commented several times
before one of the things that I think
will be true in the future is that sort
of everything will be made of computers
that every piece of material will be in
some sense programmable just like many
materials today are synthetic in the
sense that you didn't mine them out of
the ground they were made somehow and in
chemical reactions that we controlled or
whatever else and similarly I think
things will be sort of readily
everything will be programmable whether
it's the textiles that got mentioned
earlier or or other things and I think
when computation becomes that cheap
there'll be a whole range of other types
of uses for it that we haven't
anticipated
yet um M comments if someone had
invented calculus in the Stone Age it
probably would not have been used for
anything do you think there are ideas
that may be rediscovered because they
have a use in the future
absolutely I think there are things
where uh you know there are ideas that
get sometimes the ideas are not really
even
recognizable you know you could try to
argue I don't know whether this argument
will really work that the invention of
the idea of of an immortal soul from
however long ago in in kind of Theology
and other areas that that idea is kind
of an idea that's like formal
mathematics formal computation and so on
that the concept that there could be a
thing that is sort of thinking like that
is purely abstract you could say that
was that idea now there wasn't a direct
link between that idea and the actual
emergence of sort of the modern notion
of computation and and that really you
have to go back from the modern notion
of computation to read backwards into
that kind of connection so unfortunately
you know ideas before their time and
without context are sometimes very uh
very hard to um uh they don't you know
it ends up that at best you go back and
you look and say oh it's cute that was
invented there we see that in a bunch of
science fiction movies of like oh gosh
that's cute you know now this you know
video conferencing works like it did in
2001 actually it doesn't quite but um uh
you know in in um uh we can kind of read
back to these things in terms of
ideas that I mean there have been sort
of these persistent ideas about you know
artificial life or about um uh being
able to do you know read human thoughts
from a distance these kinds of things
there have been persistent ideas like
that but they don't really actualize and
perhaps eventually they will be possible
but I don't know how much the connection
between the the original pure idea and
the actualization will really be I mean
it's a question of whether I I think
there there are other things in
mathematics there plenty of areas where
people studied them and figured out
results and nobody cared at the time
that happened in lots of combinatorics
discrete mathematics number theory in
the uh in the 19th century early part of
the 20th century and for example in
number Theory there were things that
sort of emerged as important in
cryptography things that were emerged as
connected to uh kind of analytical
calculations algebra geometry and so on
which only got context later even though
they were discovered as theorems earlier
so yeah it certainly has happened in
mathematics where mathematics has this
nice feature that once you have the
theorem it's there and it can be stated
sort of without context so to
speak um although
I have to say um the uh you know when I
say that's there if you change the
axioms out from underneath if if you
decide well actually you know UK's fifth
postulate the parallel lines never never
meet you say we're not going to do
geometry that way then a lot of the
things that might have gotten proved in
that Tower of geometry sort of was okay
in that case but it might not be in
other cases all kind of go by the wayist
side and you have to kind of introduce
something new and
different let's see
uh well I should probably I see other
questions here but I also see a reminder
that I got to go back to some day job
activities here well thanks for for lots
of really interesting questions and
comments and they've gotten me to think
about some things I hope this has been
interesting to you folk and uh gets you
maybe to think about some some things a
little bit differently um and and uh I
should sign off and go to my other
things so thanks for joining me and bye
for
now